look none of us like to face the
consequences of our own actions
especially when those consequences feel
manipulated and out of proportion
[Music]
hey there folks this video is going to
be interesting because depending on how
you choose to look at it
this could basically be the closest I
ever come to talking about
cancel culture
God I hate that phrase
not because it is impossible to have use
but it's become so diluted by people
just applying it to anything they don't
like that the only term that has become
more useless than that is woke
these are completely diluted and
pointless phrases but
related to the concept at least of
cancel culture is the root idea of
accountability
and I think most of us can agree
accountability is a good thing
we should be held accountable to things
we do and say and I think a lot of us
have gone long stretches of Our Lives
seeing people
doing not great stuff and not being held
accountable in any way and this can run
the gamut from just
flat out illegal activities to
technically illegal but deeply morally
dubious ones to just
being a real piece of trash
and these things vary of course but
it's nice to at least think that people
can and will be held accountable for the
things that they do even though
at least my lifetime is borne out that
that largely doesn't happen
sometimes yeah sure now and then
way too many times it doesn't though
but that's not really what I want to
talk about
I want to talk about when accountability
has a concept and as an action
gets weaponized and gets wielded
as a means to take somebody down
now this is not to say like oh
somebody's trying to hold someone
accountable I bet it's a hit piece no
that's where we get into the
conspiratorial cancel culture narrative
nonsense but it would be disingenuous
to not at least acknowledge the fact
that sometimes
things masquerade as accountability
when they're really just a form of
targeted harassment I think probably one
of the most famous examples about that
was James Gunn's firing from the Disney
Corporation
because
what happened there was tweets that were
years old and they had to be years old
because they hadn't done anything like
this in a long time which were
admittedly
off-color importation just not good
jokes were brought forward
here's the thing Disney saw that
heard calls to get rid of James Gunn
panicked and fired him before he could
start filming Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 on its original schedule
what was realized fairly quickly after
that though this was not homegrown
genuine outrage this was deliberately
orchestrated by a bunch of trump
supporters who didn't like the fact that
James Gunn said mean things about Trump
and so they went through his Twitter
backlog they dug this stuff up and they
made a big deal out of it and they had
to go years back because the man hadn't
done it a long time and in fact had made
multiple public statements and
interviews confronting the fact that he
used to be an edge Lord and talking
about wanting to get better which he had
demonstrably done
that was weaponized accountability that
was claiming he should be held
accountable for the things he said these
horrible things that he said
which you know it was jokes it was
humorous it was bad humor but like these
horrible jokes that he said he should
lose his job but it they were wielding
it as a weapon not as just we think he
should answer for this they wanted a
specific outcome they wanted him fired
and they got it at least initially of
course then he was immediately hired
over at DC came back to uh Disney and
Marvel to do guardians 3 and is now
heading up the entire DC project so you
know but I think that works as a very
strong solid go-to example that people
are familiar with at this point
that is by no means the only instance I
am not going to be going through a bunch
more individual examples I cited James
Gunn because he is a very clear-cut case
and I don't think I'm going to get a lot
of arguments about my characterization
of what happened to him but I will say
that there are things that I have seen
over this last year including to people
who I know personally and I am seeing
this weaponization of accountability and
I know how easy it is for people who are
largely aligned with me in many ways to
jump on that and get
to be honest tricked by it
because this is something that I'm going
to use a term that's another thing is
Broad to the point of being almost
useless but the left
it's very easy to weaponize
accountability against the left not so
much the right because the right doesn't
really care
they don't really care what somebody did
as long as that person is pushing for
the things they want that's why trying
to hold Trump accountable even now
is not diminishing his poll numbers very
much because people want what they
believe he will do and they don't really
care about him ever being held
accountable for
anything
now that's not to say that there's never
been accountability on the right it's
happened sometimes but it feels like
it's happened increasingly less as time
has gone on because you know you can go
back some years and see things like Bill
O'Reilly Roger Ailes people who were
held accountable for things that they
did
and lost positions of power
but that seems increasingly rare
especially over on the right by and
large accountability only really works
if the audience of the person you're
trying to hold accountable cares
and at least from the outside looking in
the right behind large just doesn't care
they just don't
the left does though the left gets a lot
more hung up on the idea of holding
ourselves to the standard that we want
others to be held to and I'm not even
saying that necessarily as a criticism
in the broad Strokes it can lead to
miscalculations and moves that are done
for the principle of the thing that
ultimately are
going to turn out to be a bad idea or
have in the past but again I'm not I'm
not here aside a million examples but
accountability can get used and
weaponized against left-leaning
um content creators or left-leaning
figures be they government public
whatever because the left-leaning
audience and fan base cares a lot more
about accountability and because they
care
they can be whipped up
into a frenzy
by a bad actor
so ultimately what I'm going to be doing
is offering some guidance some things to
keep in mind some things to watch for
when you see what looks like the
cancellation or somebody be trying to be
held accountable for something
because I think another thing the left
is very used to is being disappointed by
the people who we put Faith in initially
and
we are kind of primed to just go oh
that one too huh and just accept that oh
this person that I respected turned out
to be horrible as well it's a very easy
thing to fall into but here's some stuff
to keep in mind and think of this in a
similar way as watching out for
confirmation bias like when you see a
headline that like seems to confirm
something you already believe that and
it like gets shared on Facebook or
Twitter or whatever
if you have been making a point of
learning like okay wait a minute what's
the source is anybody else saying that
same thing or am I just inclined to
believe it because it's what I would
like to be the case or it's what I
already believe to be the case
this is going to be similar to watching
out for confirmation bias so
some things to keep in mind when you
start seeing a frenzy being whipped up
against
honestly anybody
and you want to try and gauge how valid
is this accountability here's the things
to keep in mind I have come up with the
first is the source
who is it that is talking about this and
this is honestly you have to drill down
and try and figure out who started
bringing this up because unfortunately
in the social media age this stuff
spreads real fast so trying to backtrack
it to where it started can sometimes be
tricky but assuming that you can find an
original Source or as close to one as
you can get
you're probably going to find one of
three things
somebody who has direct personal
involvement in whatever the thing is
that accountability is being called for
so a theoretical witness to or potential
victim of whatever happened so personal
involvement
two
drama farmers
these are going to be the people who
that's just what they've made their
career on pointing out when somebody
missteps oh this person did this this
person said that it's honestly kind of
the left's answer to the outrage
Merchants that I have talked about
before you know the everything is woke
everything is sjw diversity is always
terrible yeah those people the left's
equivalent to that is the drama Farmers
the ones who are always on the prowl for
somebody messing up especially if that's
somebody who's also on the left because
ooh uh internal struggle that really
drives the algorithm so there's them and
you should always be skeptical of a
drama farmer I'm not going to judge you
for engaging with that kind of content
because there can be a sense of
entertainment or even schadenfreude to
it but just be cautious if a significant
portion and especially if the majority
of what a content creator seems to do is
complain about and dig up dirt on other
people especially other content creators
you might be dealing with a drama farmer
and you should be skeptical of most of
what they say that's not to say they can
never be right because some of them will
dig up stuff that
um is worth digging up they found
something that somebody buried that
actually they should be held accountable
for so don't 100 discount it but these
are things to keep in mind and reasons
to give it more scrutiny and then the
third who are going to be talking about
it are people who are intending to build
a narrative now that sounds a little
vague because it is honestly this is
what I do on the rare occasions when I
talk about specific figures being held
accountable in some way like when I
talked about Channel awesome like when I
talked about Illuminati
I was building narratives in particular
in those cases I was building narratives
about how to handle or not handle these
kinds of content creator scandals and I
had specific ideas that I went into with
but also worked and reshaped to figure
out how these instances fit into the
World As I understood it so I talked
about those things because they
highlighted something that I already
wanted to talk about in the case of
Channel awesome it was the more broad
sort of
you know what did they do right what did
they do wrong and with Illuminati it was
a bit more specific to why is this
hitting her harder than it seems like it
should since she's doing what on paper
seems right these brought up things that
I otherwise wanted to talk about they
allowed me to give the narrative I
wanted to tell
so again this is neither inherently good
nor inherently bad using an instance of
accountability and somebody being held
to it and or joining in on a call for
accountability
using it to tell a narrative could be
good or could be bad depending on how
good the research is whether they're
vetting what they're talking about and
whether the narrative is a harmful one
or not so that's another thing to just
watch out for it's kind of neutral and
can go either way but those are the
three types of things that you are going
to be looking for and you are going to
be putting a different measure on each
one in terms of somebody personally
involved
is there corroborating evidence are they
the only ones saying this is there more
than one person personally involved and
honestly a lot of times people tend to
come out of the woodwork drama farmers
are they credible because some drama
farmers
put more effort in I'll go with that and
then is the narrative being built one
worth telling and does this story
actually fit that narrative or is it
being bent or broken to fit that
narrative
things to keep in mind next up a really
big key thing for me especially
how long ago did this happen the thing
that we're trying to hold somebody
accountable for now there isn't a
specific statute of limitations on
accountability and how much time has
actually passed and whether or not that
matters has got to kind of depend on
what the thing the person supposedly did
was because there are some things that
honestly it shouldn't matter how long
ago it was
like I I I I Feel Like We can agree that
there are some things and your list of
things might be different from mine but
like some things like I don't care how
long ago it was
you should be held accountable for that
but then there are other things like
wait that was how long ago and that's
where referencing James Gunn also again
comes in really handy because the tweets
that he was fired over were years old
but it's not just the passage of time
have they demonstrated that they have
gotten better
that also factors into whether or not
the thing that they are trying to be
held accountable for was a one-off
or a pattern of behavior so again to use
James Gunn it was a pattern of behavior
he did these kind of edgy awful jokes a
lot
but he also stopped
and he went years without doing them and
he hasn't started doing them again
and that's where how much time has
passed matters so whenever you see
somebody digging up hey this person did
this five years ago
unless it is an action that falls under
your heading of I can't deal with
somebody having done that ever then
think to yourself why'd they have to go
that far back
why couldn't they find a pattern of more
recent Behavior which of course then
brings up the idea has this been
addressed before and again in the case
of James Gunn it had been he'd talked
about it already because sometimes even
if it was a long time ago and even if
there is an improvement in the behavior
it's still possible that it was never
properly acknowledged and reckoned with
so sometimes there maybe should still be
some accountability if only to get the
person to acknowledge publicly yes I
understand that that was wrong you
shouldn't just assume that because so
far as we are aware they don't do that
anymore that they understand what is
wrong getting an apology and getting
them to demonstrate that they understand
why something that they did was not okay
yeah that matters there's always the
issue of how much evidence is there to
support whatever it is the
accountability uh is and obviously if
it's an action against a person you know
are there Witnesses has this happened to
more than one person if this is uh an
online sort of incident like
how many people have receipts to this
how uh how much do we trust them and
here's where I'm just going to briefly
talk on the idea of likes because I see
it very frequently brought up that
people will go hey this person liked
these tweets from this horrible person
and you got to be careful with tweets
I'd say well here's the first thing I'll
say
try to hold somebody accountable for
liking things like tweets or Instagram
posts
condemning them for their likes alone
I think to me at least feels dicey I
think likes can work very well as
supporting evidence of something else
that you also have
um some some kind of evidence or
confirmation of so like if somebody is
holding a very
dangerous belief and you can support
that like by things that not only they
have said but also things that they have
liked okay that's fine but if somebody
is trying to drum up a mob uh to hold
somebody accountable and they're just
saying oh well they've liked tweets and
Instagram posts by this person this
person and this person and even if those
are bad people if they're not going to
tell you what the specific post or
tweets tweets were
I'm gonna be skeptical because
you don't vet everybody that you ever
like a tweet from
I know it's a joke like oh who likes by
accident it's not that you like by
accidents that you might not know the
full details of who the heck it was who
posted it who has the time to vet every
single interaction they have out in the
wild of the freaking internet nobody
now does that mean that maybe they
shouldn't be notified of like hey maybe
don't like that person no I like maybe
bring that to their attention politely
this is the point where I point out do
not harass anybody
be it someone who is trying to be held
accountable or the people trying to hold
that person accountable don't harass
anybody I shouldn't have to say that
but I'm gonna and we're gonna move on
but anyways likes are decent for
supporting evidence but
generally the quality of that has to do
with is there a problem with the
specific post that was liked
or just who it came from
because
sometimes
you don't know that there's a problem
with the person whose post or tweet you
liked
sometimes it's worded in a way that has
dog whistles that you don't know and
don't recognize and again volume matters
have you like has the person liked this
sort of thing a lot or a couple of times
so again another measure to keep in mind
now here's the big one for me
the use of someone's own words
if the thing that somebody is trying to
be held accountable for or get canceled
for is a clip video or audio of their
own words
how much context do we have
and how much context is being provided
by the people shouting that they should
be held accountable now again I am not
going to cite specific examples here
just because it's going to start fights
in the comments however I do have some
very specific examples in mind for this
sort of thing
context is everything and that applies
to every other point that I've brought
up in all of this context is King
the context of what else has this person
done what else has this person said and
what is the full context of the clip you
are using of them
because if somebody is passing around a
30 second or a minute clip of somebody
and they're not linking you to the
entire source
why
what context do they not want you to
have
because the reason to not like there can
be a reason to not just give people the
whatever the original Source says
depending on the length and how long the
relevant section is maybe you can't
expect people to watch that but
you should be able to have the snippet
that you're saying they should be held
accountable for but then also provide a
link and the way for people to find the
full context in which that appeared so
that people can be sure you did not put
your thumb on the scale
because
sometimes when you look into the full
context of audio and video clips
the context
is immediately apparent and it's also
immediately apparent why they didn't
include it
it can get really blatant sometimes
context is King
and context is not just the full
original Source but also the context of
what else has this person done and said
so if something feels like it doesn't
fit
question it don't automatically assume
that's not the case because sometimes
like when I talked about Illuminati
what we were hearing felt like it didn't
fit who her audience thought she was now
as the evidence piled up to support the
reveal of what kind of person she
actually was that's why her audience
turned on her again I did a whole video
on this but they turned on her because
the full evidence was provided but
initially they were skeptical because
the context of the image she built
didn't fit that and so full evidence and
receipts were kind of needed
and since they were able to be provided
what happened is what happened I said I
wouldn't cite specific examples I'm not
going to talk about any of the ones that
inspired this but I'm going to bring up
a vintage one
Blair white is the queen of out of
context Clips she lives
to snip out tiny bits of things that
people have said
and just tear those things apart and
paint an image
of the person who said that or an image
of what it was they said that is
incomplete contradiction she loves to
put fake quotes in the titles of her
videos and pretend that the person whose
head she sticks in a thumbnail said
those exact things yes I do have a
personal stake in this and actually you
know what
I'm gonna let somebody else sum this up
because he did it really well another
video right here called I'm transgender
for attention which is also in quotation
marks and the person in this video also
never said that I went back and found
the original video she's reacting to
because at this point I have to fact
check everything but he's doing and in
this video this person is talking about
how her experience doesn't take away
from other people's experiences and
Blair flips it it makes it sound like
she's saying the opposite and honestly
Blair White's somebody that should have
thrown up a bunch of red flags because
all she ever did
was provide tiny Snippets of a person
tiny instances
either from only one video or only one
article that was written or only one
interview
and then just go off on that not provide
multiple sources not cite multiple
things
strip as much context as possible
so that she could build the narrative
she wanted
Blair white is both
fitting people into the narrative that
she wants and a drama farmer she does
both
so there is overlap as well and it is
possible for even people who are
directly personally involved in some of
these things do also be drama Farmers or
want to build a narrative
the things that I've laid out before are
types and you can multi-class in these
things
and I don't know how helpful all this is
ultimately for people I don't know who's
gonna watch this all the way through to
the end
I don't
I was gonna say I don't know who needs
to hear this I know a lot of people who
need to hear this I don't know how many
of the people who need to hear this will
listen
but I've seen the notion of
accountability which is a good thing
wield it as a weapon
too many times in this last year
and wielded in a way that if more people
just stopped and paused and thought wait
what's the context of this it was how
long ago how much evidence is there for
this who's the source
if these questions got asked by more
people this stuff wouldn't get as big as
it does
and we wouldn't see people like James
Gunn getting fired
but we do still see it
because
it's easy to do less work
if it fits a narrative we already
Believe coming back to confirmation bias
confirmation bias isn't a thing people
do because they're evil
we do it because it feels like oh well I
don't have to do work then that fits
what I already believe cool
trying to navigate this age
this time in which we live is
work
it's a lot
of work and if you're not up for doing
that work
I get it I only have so many spoons of
the day too
but in that if that's the case maybe
you don't spend a few spoons you have
taking part in a accountability mob
if you have the spoons to do that maybe
step back take a breath have a cup of
tea and look into it a little more first
I don't know
again I don't know how helpful this will
actually be for people I don't know if
they'll think I'm condescending for
laying stuff out the way that I have
because I think in their heart of hearts
most people know
most of what I've said
but they either choose not to do it or
they don't have the energy for it
was this just an exercise in uh me just
venting in a way why don't people do
this I don't know maybe
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it uh be careful
citing specific examples that you think
Illustrated any of the things I said
only because that stuff tends to derail
the comments I'm not gonna say you can't
cite specific examples just
be careful doing so try not to get into
fights in my comment sections and the
older an example you can use probably
the better avoiding the fresher stuff
might be in everybody's best interest
I have to moderate these comments
actually myself folks
cut me some slack
but if you want to support what I do
patreon's the best way to do that uh and
if you can't support me that way or if
you already are links in the description
there's other things that I do other
platforms that I'm on I've merged books
Etc
check them out but don't worry too much
about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
shout out to the patrons who helped make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida to rock the thing that goes doing
from the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Auntie
Kate 808 Becky Sparks pranabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scravid
angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards on the patreon
you can check out the tiers but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
[Music]
thank you